I was raised with a Tarion.
Um,
and
my mother said she took us to church so
that we wouldn't,
uh,
okay.
Get religious later in life.
She was above and both my parents were
atheists and my grandmother was an
atheist and in rural Kentucky.
And so they were trying to make sure
that my brother and I would be atheist
too.
And it worked,
which doesn't mean that we didn't,
they didn't teach us a lot of,
uh,
sort of wonder of science and of nature
in the world and all of that.
I think they gave us all of that,
but they are
both highly skeptical people.
I got that
to be,
um,
yeah,
no,
it,
it didn't,
the only problem was that my mother's
parents were southern Baptists and
devout and it was very upsetting them to
the idea,
mmm.
That we didn't believe in God.
So I told him that I did because I
thought that was really cool because
they were worried that we would go to
hell.
So,
um,
my grandmother asked me
once,
she said,
I don't care about anything except that
you count what you believe in God.
I think in this next one I'm working on
for sure because it
definitely reared its head in modern day
talking.
And I mean,
I,
I just came from an interview where
Lewis Black was coming in right after me
and I had met him before and we talked
about all of this.
And,
um,
it's everywhere.
Everyone's talking.
There's,
there's of course,
a huge evangelical movement recently and
now there's a,
there's an atheist movement that often
seems to me,
I was raised to be really nice to people
and kind of out there beliefs.
Um,
and so a lot of it seems really overly
self righteous,
odd.
Like in the same way that evangelicals
are where it is.
I just think it's not,
I don't believe any of that stuff,
but I don't,
not mad about it.